le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
parfois les aléas de la vie faut que des
parents doivent se séparer de leurs
enfants pour une période plus ou moins
longue
les assistants familiaux sont des
professionnels qui accueillent à leur
domicile ses gènes plus qu'un métier
c'est une vocation qui demande de
grandes qualités humaines et éducative
rencontre avec marie annick qui veille
sur ses deux protégés depuis 14 ans
[Musique]
ça c'est le devoir pour le maire
ambiance studieuse sur les hauts de
saint gilles les deux adolescents de la
maison sont concentrés sur leur
dissertation sous l'oeil attentif de
marie-annick elle n'est pas leur mère
elle n'est même pas de leur famille
pourtant c'est elle qui veille sur ses
deux jumeaux depuis qu'ils ont deux ans
car mariannick est assistante familiale
je suis centrale depuis l'année 2004 et
je suis diplômé d'état depuis l'année
2010 au départ moi j'ai accueilli deux
enfants qui sont maintenant des ados de
15 ans et par la suite chacun aussi des
enfants pendant les vacances scolaires
aussi
donc j'ai un agrément pour trois enfants
des enfants qu'il faut accueillir dans
de bonnes conditions
à chacun son histoire à chacun ses
problématiques
le but leur offrir un nouvel équilibre
dans un environnement adapté est
rassurant c'est d'un accompagnement à
travers l'autonomie la socialisation
le
les couteaux 6
le marquage voilà endosser un rôle de
protecteur bienveillant sans ce
subtilisé pour autant aux parents
d'origine un équilibre délicat à trouver
pour marie annick saab ouvéa c'est quand
même mon quotidien mes moments riches en
émotions une joie aussi mais aussi une
appréhension de pouvoir les appeler y
est allé recevoir les accompagner ça se
passe bien la plupart du temps mais il
ya aussi des moments difficiles par
exemple des petits conflits entre eux
aussi vous vouliez au collège à l'école
donc on en parle on en parle à chaque
fois que toujours est en écoute dans la
communication pour pouvoir résoudre les
petits problèmes
les assistants familiaux sont agréés par
le département pour les préparer à gérer
ces situations parfois difficiles
la collectivité les accompagne à travers
des stages et des formations vos appuis
177 personnes à travailler au quotidien
au service de la collectivité
c'est un métier à part entière qui
demande bien sûr de l'école
l'instance du dialogue mais aussi qui
demande à ce que les assistants
familiaux donne de l'amour à ses enfants
mais à six voies le travail que vous
faites le travail de qualité un travail
remarquable travail c'est difficile mais
ô combien utile pour le bien-être de nos
enfants de la rue les devoirs terminée
c'est l'heure pour les jumeaux de se
livrer à leur passion le foot peut aller
jusqu'à l'équipe de france pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas très impliqué dans
l'éducation des deux frères lui aussi
c'est le conjoint de marie annick qui
les conduit au terrain quand je n'ai pas
comme d'hab là bas
pour cette famille atypique à défaut des
liens du sang le temps et la patience
ont fait naître l'essentiel les liens du
coeur
[Musique]
un assistant familial est un
professionnel qui accueille de façon
permanente un à trois mineurs majeurs de
moins de 21 ans et son domicile
son rôle est d'offrir à ses enfants
séparés de leur foyer un cadre éducatif
et des conditions de vie idéal pour leur
développement pour devenir assistant
familial
il faut obtenir un agrément du
département un stage préparatoire de 60
heures est obligatoire avant tout
accueil et l'assistant peut obtenir son
diplôme d'état après une formation en
alternance de 240 heures pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez contacter le
service central au 02 62 90 33 24 ou
vous rendre sur le site du département
au www.defirh.fr cap.fr lien social
accompagne les réunionnais pour la
mobilité
[Musique]
moi je partais en irlande du nord du
coup et on savait pas comment c'était la
vie là-bas je savais pas si mon anglais
allaient s'y fie
[Musique]
on est dépaysé qu'on arrive à daya pas
de regret saucisses en irlande
si je regarde moi d'il ya trois ans de
ça j'ai pas autant de confiance en moi
en mes capacités d'être indépendant de
vraiment dire que je peux me débrouiller
au niveau maturité qu'on se retrouve
dans complètement en dehors de sa zone
de confort dans un pays on connaît
absolument personne où on parle la
langue mais juste juste et tout est bon
ça ça fait vraiment grandir les gens
mais vraiment un seul coup
[Musique]